welcome to bananamores this next
comedian makes my belly laugh every time
i hear her perform
get ready to do the same introducing
chalewa shop oh mitzy
it's always good to see you
you dame oh hi everyone
how are you guys doing how are you
holding up
yeah oh boy i'm just uh
taking a little breather from work i've
been
lucky enough to work from home you know
i think i mean
i'm not doing anything
and i'm still getting paid so
i'm not going to rock the boat you know
what i mean
right yeah i think i think the issue is
that i'm i'm an office manager
but we are all working from home
which takes the office out of the
equation
and i am not entirely sure what i'm
managing
oh not much it feels like here's what
i'm doing every day
monday through friday here's what i do
i get up i take a shower
i get dressed i grab my
things i run outside of my apartment
and then i stand outside of my apartment
door
until i am exactly eight minutes late
and then i rush back into my apartment
and i drop my things and i say something
to my cat about the trains
and then i email all of my co-workers to
make sure that they are drinking
terrible coffee
and then i'm kind of done for the day
you know just sit back
kick your feet up drink terrible coffee
in solidarity it's not bad it's not bad
i will say this i am i work with
wonderful people
but i do not miss having to make small
talk with them
oh i tru they're lovely folks but i'm
very bad at small talk
you know did you ever have a hiding spot
at your job to keep from having small
talk like
did you just like hide behind a filing
cabinet or something uh here's what i
would do
i would um i would sit at my desk
and i would make myself very small
just in the hopes that no one would see
me
over my monitor you know
it usually worked um except
for the fact that my desk is the front
desk
and it is literally my job to greet
everyone
that comes in and i am bad at it
i'm so bad at my job in person
thrilled to be doing it from home
i mean you know a co-worker would come
by and say hey did you
how about this weather did you hear
about the and i would just
you can cut that chitten and chatting
out that is not why i'm here
i am here for the wi-fi
if you'll excuse me i have a spinning
wheel to attend to
okay i'm just uh i'm not good with
people i'm just not much of a people
person
um once i uh i went to
brunch with three couples
i don't think that's my fault you know
what i mean like
one couple invited me and then when i
got there i thought oh
well you you should have told me i would
have hired someone to come with me
to this isn't fair this is not fair
there came a moment when uh when the
waitress came by and they stopped her
to tell her how to separate the checks
so they they stopped the waitress and
they said
okay so these two people here
they're on one check and then these two
they're on another and this is exactly
what the waitress did
she looked at us and said
yeah i think i can figure this out
oh really you uh you cracked the case
what uh what was the first clue was it
that we're sitting at a
six top table and i'm the only one with
a plate in my lap
is that how you got it yeah that's great
that's great
but i do have to say that when the
checks arrived
i was the only one who didn't have to
have that quiet yet furious conversation
with someone else to figure out how
we're going to pay for these 18
eggs i just tossed down my debit card
and said overdrawn all by myself i don't
need a man
i sure don't you can get any money off
of that card
eggs on me forever all legs on me
all eggs on me oh
mitzi you know what i don't want to take
up any more of your time
so i'm just going to get going but uh
thank you for letting me come up here
and tell
my little jokes my name's chile rashard
thank you very much
a banana more's instant legend the
banana more stage is lucky to have that
chalewa sharp let me tell you i'm gonna
tell you